Identification. This is session five. Interview with faith.
Bandler and Carolyn Craig recorded in Sydney on Friday the twentieth of June one nine hundred ninety seven.
The interview begins in approximately ten seconds time and if identification. Faith. When did you come to Sydney.
I came to Sydney in nineteen forty. And the war. Was already long. That Australia was not.
Heavily involved with the war because the Japanese had not yet. The American base. Anyhow. Now I had a fairy godmother.
And her name was Lucy. Lucy came from a very wealthy family in the north okaying growers now Lucy.
I had a family of four all grown up a little older than me. And she needed help.
Because she lived most of the time in Sydney. In a beautiful beautiful magnificent place.
On a cliff to gardens and so we had an agreement. As it were that. I would help in the house and help.
And she would give me certain. It wasn't didn't dream and it just happened.
She absolutely insisted that I go back and do piano which I did.
And she absolutely insisted that I practiced every afternoon. And I did sometimes from twelve in the day.
Right through until seven or eight or whatever at night and. She just. Made me do things to sing.
And she had a sister in law his name was Lady. Again the mother of little. Who was a very good pianist.
She actually lived at the spit and she would come over on a Sunday.
And Mrs Walker would absolutely insist that all my music. And sing. Sister in law put accompany me.
Well for the Japanese and there were other things she didn't like.
And she'd help me fitted dress and all this kind of thing.
She was a woman with an amazing how well most beautiful people I've ever met.
You know where it was sort of a mother for me
and she you see I go out in the morning pick up the Sydney Morning Herald make her a cup of tea put it on her tray
little book. And take it. Upstate. And she loved it just loved it but she was a wonderful person.
It was the second time she'd been through. She'd lost her brothers in the first world. And now.
With one brother a prisoner of war. Prisoner of war in Germany another. In the now. And after series of.
What year was this and that you came to Sydney and we did you. We were you living at this time when you knew her.
I was living in verse. Actually when I first had met her.
But and she was on her Why to Sydney after she was staying in prison for a bit but.
What was your other question it was a good one where you're talking about taking breakfast up to her I was like a way
where we were living at that time.
Oh well you see it was a huge house and our head it was as it were a little apartment of those houses.
And Clifton gardens. Yes and I had my own bathroom and a little lounge through and through an absolutely beautiful.
And the distortions of growth the window encrypted through the right wing's was heavenly.
And I travel to and from of course on the. And that's how it was that I happened to be going.
When the Japanese the not the Japanese submarines came into the. Well now infant or not.
Perhaps I would never have been able to do a lot of the things I have done in my life.
She always looked on me as though I could do anything. It wouldn't matter what it was can do it as it were. And.
She instilled a lot of pride in me and some have made me value. Integrity almost and beautiful.
And so then one day I said Look I really would like to join the land. I mean you do that.
Well I've told you about the land.
But what I would come only she would come to the central why in her little car and me.
I would be there in my brother would come and stay with me or both.
My sister and I would stay there and she could never do. And that's how I felt about her in the car.
So it was I think made me feel that I should develop musically. Although she didn't have a great appreciation for the.
Classics as such but she enjoyed listening listening to good singing and to good music. And already they knew C.
I was already going to the concerts.
I want to talk today about this part of my life when she insisted that I take piano lessons. If I had a teacher.
And she was very good teacher by the name of Margaret Coburn. Who had a house in Jersey.
And she lived there with her parents she had a beautiful big studio.
Beautiful teacher just marvelous I went to a couple of years. She then said well look after their. And I have to go.
And here's my season ticket. You simply. Concerts and used it until I come back and I just came back.
I think she stayed over there because I didn't hear any more about what happened. I began the ticket.
I renewed it for a little while. And you know I was bitten by one truly. So then I took a nap for myself so.
I talked about my views of before and after the war of course I came back to Sydney
and I found the wasn't awfully much to live for after. Getting to those concerts in the town hall.
I wasn't particularly I was twenty six twenty seven maybe and I wasn't particularly interested in me
but they used to chase me like Christmas which I kept you never had a minute's peace. And some awful.
Wouldn't give you tuppence for you. You made hands at a concert didn't you. But that was that was a bit like.
Like when I came home that was the end of ninety and forty five. Came back to Sydney and went back to Mrs Walker.
And it was like just being at home. I want to grow wings. I felt restricted. So within a short time.
I felt conscious of packing a suitcase and going off and I found a room. They're arming Street Kings Cross or a.
That unlike Downing Yes Downing. It was an awful place.
I cannot tell you how awful it was it was one huge and in that there was a gas ring in the corner.
Where you could heat your water. For about half and you would have washed down it wouldn't.
There was no showers in the place. There was nothing virtually just.
So I had a great big tub and the water up on the ring
and my sister shared this with me because it was so big we could share. I think we're paying. And.
And then I thought well I must get back to my music.
Because at this time during the war extensively and I want to keep this.
So I began singing around a cross and they had crossed. And it was held. I think once a month in a local theater.
And you won by acclamation. So they organized. Something Mo He had a fair bit to do with radio and.
He said or didn't you come face and enter.
And I think it was ten pounds was the first prize and it would be held on a Sunday night and all across.
There were better singers and make the work better trained singers than me.
There was no question about it but they didn't value. The quality.
You need movement just good training and I hope that even though I didn't quite know how to use it and.
I went up this night
and I was backed by a few of the blokes like I kind of had a very close friendship they knew the man.
And he's rotten and there was another Blanco's a barrister. They all said Paul come off ice let's get up there.
We'll clack clack. Well I think I have one more because I had no friends in the audience.
That had that on merit because there really was a singer who knew how to use her voice
but her top couldn't reach the top notes that I could try and as I was maybe up the long
or short of this is I wanted to have ten pounds richer. And ten. It was like a thousand today.
Do you remember the name of the feature of the street.
Oh it was right in Darling her strode I remember that was a few doors from where to Mary. Right in the heart.
There was the Arabian coffee shop and it was almost opposite.
And I talk about Iraq even coffee shop as you would know it
but you see before one did anything you know the crafts you had to go to the Arabian coffee shop.
There was upstairs there was a little over and. There. And treated customers like kings and queens.
You could sit there all night over one cup of coffee and I wouldn't view it had very much a touch of the old.
Where you didn't go for coffee. You went to meet your might read the newspapers and no one would disturb you.
And that's what the Arabian horse about.
Well I would go up there with this trick of me talking up the steps without me
and we are on the other end of the Arabian and you look down to learning this. And we drink coffee.
They hadn't blue crawfish caps and saucers
and little blue Jack said Hilda Crean did have milk with coffee with coffee and. You didn't D.C.
Just drink this black stuff. Just so happened twelve o'clock would get the hint you know.
I've walked into Downing Street now living in this room in Downing Street was the man who lived in the room below me
had to flow from the ground floor. And he was a great Gilbert and Sullivan.
Funny looking black and what he did for a living but he is just God knows what
and he had a teacher by the name of God He and Italian teacher who lived opposite on the corner of Downing Street
and King's Cross and he and his wife lived on the top floor and he that was his teacher.
And he said to me look at any charges I published and what. I see if you look you know I'm only getting a quid a week.
This is what you. Go every fortnight or so I did and that I went to got he got he was. Impatient to get me on the road.
He he didn't I had to work out my technique. And I had a clue. You know I only ALWAYS AND BEAUTIFUL know.
And I thought well I'll go to guy and he will tell me how to use my much.
My whole body but it didn't work at that way because he was very interested get me. Singing.
Well you know he was a great bloke I thought with personality and. He he had this studio.
With his grand piano and that you walked out onto that overlook.
And he would send me out on to the friend to the house. And he would play much from Tosca he loved the Arias of course.
And he made me. And he says go on to the water. I go to the water now.
I was singing a duet after the sale of part of the.
From task forgotten the title and this bloke who was in the room below me across the room began to sing the tenor Oh.
And across Downing Street. We would do it going. And I rather like this bloke can think about his name.
But you know why he was he protected me and my sister. He kept an eye on us fairly.
Not that I felt I needed protecting but there were awful lot of blokes who used to come and hang around
and you know some would bring me always sisters
and some would bring me you know what marmalade Linfox would bring me his planning. And they'd come at all hours.
And this bloke Antony would keep an eye out. You know if there was a knock on the door.
He'd make sure he'd make sure I was all right.
But there was a scientist from the water boat who made it terrible nuisance of himself
and so my friend the singer Billy. Sit would you like me to speak to you.
I said just a matter of fact and he did it in no uncertain and I was given some peace. Anyhow.
And they began and I rather enjoyed that part of my life.
You know going across the road and singing to the harbor waters and all that and the thing and then the bloke
and I remember Larry said to me. Now he says look he doesn't teach us how to breathe. And if you like.
If you ask your own great. So he did so we would exchange. And I would tell him how to get up. OK.
And where it should be there. Oh there. What have you. Well.
Things changed a bit and what all these men who hunger and I will own
and if not to the communist party they belong to label. And I began to become very political.
And I would join them like New Year's Eve night in the cross was what. Of cross point.
Rush cut is by not put gas in the cross. Normal circumstances. Every Sunday night. You want a citizen of the cross.
If you didn't go out on the street and look for your group. And you'd find on one corner the. Labor.
Right at the corner Labor left another corner of the trust a corner of the communists and so it would go on
and so you'd kind of find your niche.
They wouldn't you know Sunday night and but somehow when you see night would come.
The political differences would be banished and people would just drove but back and greeting each other.
It was just wonderful. And then at midnight. We there. Just the street and the cross had a big place in my.
My whole body. You mentioned a merry Gilmore. I didn't make Dame Mary until a better ninety. Fifty.
And she lived there and one other things I remember saying I can't remember how I first met her
but she invited me up for a cup of tea.
And I sent a little note asking her if I could go on a certain day
and she sent a little note back saying yes of course do come child.
And she had a door it's true on the inside but always remember this. You know.
They say it's not safe to walk our streets meaning they need trouble. She would have been say ninety there.
Had any trouble at all. And I thought that was just beautiful. Yes.
Did you mean I mean it was such a hey me and community in those days and political community did you meet people like.
Douglas Steele and Margaret Cullen and people like that. Well. Douglas Stewart. Cohen. But I did.
Already know they artist. And that. And I met. I think it was my brow lift. In part which was Potts Point you know.
In my play St Di mayor was there. Of course but I suppose the most important people of all who were there.
Paul Williams and his wife Bobbie. And I lived in Tuscan I'm straight. They had a flat they had a one bedroom flat.
And then I had the lounge and a kitchenette you couldn't swing a cat
and prepare me for some food in the kitchen it shall never forget it that when I met Bobby and Paul.
They had only just married. I had already had made Paul's previous wife. Lily.
And Lily just want to talk about Lily for a moment leaves a beautiful woman.
That she was a dedicated member of the Communist Party. She lived. In a pocket units that are very independent.
And she lived and she had the plague.
Because it was very doubt that she realized she was very fortunate because those days you couldn't get a place to live
not for the love of not even for a million dollars There was nothing after just nothing that I had this room
and darling stage I thought I was among one of the most fortunate of all people.
Well lived there and it was a self-contained good in good condition and she had a lot of men friends who were.
Very political extremely political lived for their parties the Labor Party or Conyers Pat. And some kind of adopted me.
It's hard to explain. She wanted me to do great things.
And I just wanted to be bloody lazy and sing around the place and. You know knock about a bit. And she took to be back.
Marx and Engels and I thought I couldn't care less. I couldn't care less so.
Then one day she said to me you know if you should join the party.
And I say for a moment I thought during the party of all her friends.
And I said which party she says there is only one party. There is nothing else.
A lot of the laughter probably ought to be good. This was the Communist Party.
Yes yes that we agreed to be afraid this in spite of the fact that our joining any cause any party after all
and we went to concerts together that was what I enjoy it immensely. And she had to be played in the Christian.
Who would get tickets. For special concerts and what have you and she always took me one.
She had contacts there was no question about it and she knew everyone who played in the local stores
but there's no doubt about that but she was also afraid of being in a good ski.
Now do you know if that one means anything to you Carol. But he was a very he was a spy.
And he became rather prominent during the Petrov commission. And he played the violin in your Christer.
I won't go into details or bad people or go skiing.
Having mentioned its name in the commission if ever I write this up I will certainly in large because it was a very
terrible time it was a dreadful. So if you come back to Paul.
Lee made a bloody nuisance of herself because she and Paul had divorced and Paul had married.
Paul fell on his feet hear voices singing teacher marrying this magnificent young just thirty he is here.
And she would accompany all his stars. I mean he couldn't have had a better. But. Tremendous impact on her life.
It was quite unbelievable I look back on it now. That's right. Lily said to me look.
You give that he tell you know why he's not teaching you how to sing that all he's just enjoying you.
You give him away. And you go to a pole. I did precisely that.
And I realized then but they were happy happy times with gaiety the Italian teacher
and I had no regrets it took me nothing. He just made me keep to keep singing high notes and to sink to the water.
Well cannot happen after that.
So I thought it was time to get down to serious business
and at least if you go to poor old school had Lillian Paul immigrated from Europe or they stray and. Born.
They both come out in one thousand nine hundred thirty nine hundred thirty. You know.
After the Nazis walked into the here and both.
Paul had a very interesting life but they couldn't live under the same roof and would also of their own.
So they're divorced out here. They were married when I came out.
Anyhow I found that going to Paul's and obvious place was more than going for a music listener also
but the music lesson was conducted very professional very. And for the first half hour. I would do the scales.
And then he showed me how to develop and develop the. Way to hold the breath and normalize it and.
He was very very particular and nobody in a student of his would he encouraged to sing. Hubert in English.
So I began to take German license from him for some reason or other a new bit of German for that.
And so forth and awfully difficult to. I would go for a German lesson. And that.
I had practically a pair for my rent there was nothing left in that thing.
You know I don't do old clothes and remake them and only kind of think. How were you in your living at that point.
That was when I was infected in a shirt factory.
That day and it wasn't tough
and the person who owned it was a family with whom I had beautiful friendship with his daughters.
And it was a regular money and I was tough and strong. You know me and they paid me well.
And it was enough to make the cost of my music lessons and to pay the rent.
And the blacks would bring me food and this kind of thing. But.